when writing a story do you think it's
important to write the story around a
transmedia like structure or to extend
it to transmedia after you have already
developed a story so when you're
developing when you're developing
stories I think you have to you have to
understand that you have to execute this
single story by itself no matter what
other transmedia idea that you have I
think the tendency can be I get so
focused on all the all the stories that
that that I don't execute any individual
individual story the right way and that
that that's a mistake
because you have to understand if if if
your movie isn't good if your script
isn't good nothing works
if you're if your TV pilot isn't good
nothing works
now what I would say is I'm a fan of of
developing the transmedia plan first and
and understand understanding how all the
stories interplay and understanding your
story world and understand and where the
opportunities are and then once you have
that sort of structure and that
architecture in play and you understand
where what part of the puzzle
this individual story is then then what
you do is just then set that aside you
set all that aside and then you just got
dive in and make sure you write an
awesome script an awesome pilot and and
execute that thing but when you when you
when you're writing it you will
naturally be building in new
opportunities you'll because you'll
understand how this interplays with the
other stories you understand more about
your story world and naturally you're
going to start lacing things in that if
you hadn't done that work first you
wouldn't have which means then if you do
all the trends meet the opportunities
after the fact then one thing is gonna
one or two things would happen is you're
probably going to say oh I need to go
rewrite my script to be able to
accommodate for all these things but
then it may not feel natural or organic
or you're gonna say I'm just gonna leave
it as it is and then it feels
disconnected and you're not going to get
the the the experience that you want so
so it's it's a balance is is if you
don't develop it as you're writing I
think you develop the plan the broad
plan from an IP perspective this is my
road map the you know if if you know I'm
gonna I'm gonna drive from LA to New
York and I'm gonna look at the map and I
see my route that I'm gonna take this is
the broad route that I'm gonna take
right and map that and I understand
where I'm going I understand how to get
there but eventually I need to get in
the car
and I'm not gonna be like staring at the
map the entire time in the car
I'm in the car and I'll make minor
adjustments as I'm in the car I'll get
off a certain rest stops I'll get a
maybe take a different Road here or
there but I still already understand the
direction that I'm going the problem is
I think most people like jump in the car
and then we met a destination right they
say I'm just going to drive that it just
ends up being more work on the back end
me personally I hate to rewrite I hate
rewriting I think all writers hate
rewriting and so I want to minimize my
rewriting process as much as possible
which means then I think you you just
build you building an IP design set that
aside and then go I think that the
balance of that is sometimes tricky and
you kind of learn your way but I think
that's the best way forward
you